se realizó una investigación sobre
cuatro especies diferentes de plantas
para determinar cuál de las tres
especies era más cercana a una especie
desconocida de plantas los resultados de
la investigación se muestran en la
siguiente tabla que especie de planta
parece tener la relación más cercana con
la especie desconocida justifica tu
respuesta pausa en el vídeo y tratan de
responder a esta pregunta vemos que el
primer renglón de la tabla muestra los
datos de la especie desconocida sabemos
que da positivo para la prueba de la
enzima m la siguiente célula no tiene
información porque se refiere a las
diferencias en las secuencias de
aminoácidos que existen entre esta
especie y la especie desconocida pero
este es el renglón de la especie
desconocida por lo que no existen
diferencias pues es la misma especie
la última celda muestra el patrón de
bandas de electroforesis en gel aquí nos
vamos a enfocar en encontrar la mayor
cantidad de similitudes entre cada
especie y la especie desconocida primero
veamos qué especies dan positivo para la
prueba de la enzima m la especie a uno
no da positivo para esta enzima las
especies 2 y 3 si dan positivo
la especie 1 no se ve tan prometedora si
vemos la diferencia entre las secuencias
de aminoácidos la especie 1 nuevamente
muestra la mayor diferencia con respecto
a la especie desconocida lo que confirma
lo que pensamos de que esta especie
podría ser la de mayor diferencia con la
especie desconocida si nos fijamos en
las especies 2 y 3 la especie 2 tiene la
menor cantidad de diferencias por lo que
la especie 2 toma la delantera con
respecto a la similitud con la especie
desconocida la especie 3 tiene más
diferencias ahora veamos el patrón de
bandas de electroforesis en gel y nos
damos cuenta que la especie 2 tiene el
mismo patrón de bandas que la especie
desconocida y es la única especie que
tiene el mismo patrón esto nos da la
confianza para afirmar que la especie de
planta 2 es la más parecida a la planta
desconocida lo escribimos 2 porque tiene
el mismo patrón de bandas la menor
diferencia en las secuencias de
aminoácidos y dio positivo para la
enzima m resolvamos otro problema los
científicos intentan determinar las
relaciones evolutivas de tres especies
diferentes de pinzón a b y c para hacer
esto ellos examinaron las
características físicas y adn de estas
especies se extrajo adn de las tres
especies y se analizó usando
electroforesis en gel en el siguiente
diagrama se muestran los resultados que
enunciado describe mejor el método usado
arriba para determinar las relaciones
evolutivas entre las tres especies de
pinzón uno examina y compara las
estructuras de los picos 2 observa el
comportamiento y las características
físicas de todos los pinzones y los
agrupa por similitudes 3 obtiene
evidencia molecular de las tres especies
e identifica similitudes 4 comparan
cestos comunes a las tres especies para
ver si tienen los mismos ancestros de
nuevo pausa en el vídeo y piensen en la
opción que elegirían claramente estamos
viendo evidencia molecular ya que
tomaron adn
las diferentes especies lo amplificaron
lo que significa que se hicieron muchas
copias de ciertas secuencias de ese adn
y lo corrieron en gel lo que permite que
esos segmentos diferentes se separen de
manera que los segmentos más pequeños se
van a alejar y los segmentos más grandes
quedan más cerca y mientras más
similitudes veamos en este patrón de
bandas de electroforesis en gel es más
probable que esos adn sean similares así
que definitivamente se usa evidencia
molecular y la opción 3 es la única que
menciona este tipo de evidencia así que
esta es la opción correcta es cierto que
al inicio del enunciado mencionan que
los científicos examinaron
características físicas y el adn de
estas especies por lo que podríamos
decir que ellos examinaron y compararon
la estructura de los picos como dice la
opción 1 pero es algo muy específico y
no estamos seguros de que los
científicos hayan hecho ese tipo de
análisis específico pero si estamos
seguros de que ellos obtuvieron
evidencia molecular de las tres especies
e identificaron similitudes la siguiente
parte del problema dice con base en la
información recabada con la
electroforesis en gel
etiqueta el siguiente diagrama
ramificado escribe las letras a b ó c
para representar las posibles relaciones
evolutivas entre las especies a bs
nuevamente los invito a que pause en el
vídeo y traten de etiquetar este
diagrama con la información que nos
proporcionan en este patrón de bandas
vamos a dibujar el diagrama que nos
piden aquí nos piden etiquetar con a b y
c las ramas correspondientes una forma
de pensar en esto es que estas ramas de
aquí están más relacionadas entre sí ya
que tienen un ancestro común más
reciente en comparación con esta rama de
acá si vemos el patrón de bandas nos
damos cuenta de que estas especies
tienen la misma banda aquí así como la
misma banda acá y en la última banda
también en cambio la especie se sólo
tiene en común esta última banda con las
especies ahí ve la única banda que ahí
ve tienen en común es esta banda de acá
la especie no tiene nada más en común
con la especie se es evidente que las
especies a ive tienen más bandas en
común por lo que etiquetamos estas ramas
cercanas como ahí ve pues todo indica
que tienen un ancestro común más cercano
y etiquetó esta otra rama como se por
que es la más lejana con esto terminamos
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo